Benedicto 16 deja una profunda huella en
la iglesia católica será recordado como
un gran teólogo un nombre respetuoso de
la tradición defendió una línea
conservadora en temas como el aborto la
homosexualidad o la eutanasia fue un
gran predicador alguien que hizo
accesible a todo tipo de personas los
contenidos de la fe pero su pontificado
También estuvo marcado por escándalos y
declaraciones polémicas cuando cuestionó
el uso del preservativo en África o
cuando hizo un lazo indirecto entre
islam y violencia algo que chocó al
mundo musulmán también el escándalo
conocido como El batilix una fuga de
documentos por su mayordomo personal que
reveló al mundo la lucha de poder en el
Vaticano al batilix se le atribuyó por
mucho tiempo la causa de la renuncia de
Benedicto pero años después Benedicto
reiteró que renunció porque no sentía
más contar con las fuerzas físicas
necesarias para cumplir con la función
de papa de la Iglesia Católica Natalia y
Es la primera vez que muere un Papa
emérito Mientras hay otro jerarca en
ejercicio que es el Papa Francisco Esto
hace que el protocolo de exequias que
existe para un sumo pontífice varíe que
se sabe entonces de cómo será el funeral
será un protocolo completamente inédito
en el Vaticano en la oficina de prensa
de la santa sede confirmó que el funeral
del Papa emérito Benedicto 16 se llevará
a cabo el jueves 5 de enero a partir de
las nueve y media de la mañana en el
Vaticano la ceremonia será presidida por
el Papa Francisco la última voluntad de
Benedicto 16 fue que su funeral fuera lo
más sencillo posible además a partir del
próximo lunes el cuerpo del Papa emérito
será expuesto en la Basílica de San
Pedro para que en una capilla ardiente
para que los fieles católicos que lo
deseen puedan darle un último adiós a
Benedicto 16 el papa número 265 de la
Iglesia Católica que murió en la mañana
de este 31 de diciembre en el Vaticano